for the past 15 years I've been trying
to change your mind in my work i harness
pop culture and emerging technology to
shift cultural norms I've made video
games to promote human rights I've made
animations to raise awareness about
unfair immigration laws and I even made
location-based augmented reality apps to
change perceptions around homelessness
well before pokemons go but then I began
to wonder whether a game or an app can
really change attitudes and behaviors
and if so can I measure that change
what's the science behind that process
so I shifted my focus from making media
and technology to measuring their
neurobiological effects here's what I
discovered the web mobile devices
virtual and augmented reality were Ries
crypting our nervous systems and they
were literally changing the structure of
our brain the very technologies I had
been using to positively influence
hearts and minds we're actually eroding
functions in the brain necessary for
empathy and decision-making in fact our
dependence upon the web and mobile
devices might be taking over our
cognitive and affective faculties
rendering us socially and emotionally
incompetent and I felt complicit in this
dehumanization I realized that before I
could continue making media about social
issues I needed to reverse engineer the
harmful effects of technology to tackle
this I asked myself how can I translate
the mechanisms of empathy the cognitive
affective and motivational aspects into
an engine that simulates the narrative
ingredients that move us to act to
answer this I had to build a machine
I've been developing an open-source
biometric lab an AI system which I call
the limbic lab the
not only captures the brain and body's
unconscious response to media and
technology but also uses machine
learning to adapt content based on these
biological responses my goal is to find
out what combination of narrative
ingredients are the most appealing in
galvanizing to specific target audiences
to enable to enable social justice
cultural and educational organizations
to create more effective media the
limbic lab consists of two components
narrative engine and a media machine
while a subject is viewing or
interacting with media content the
narrative engine takes in and syncs
real-time data from brainwaves
biophysical data like heart rate blood
flow body temperature and muscle
contraction as well as eye tracking and
facial expressions data is captured at
key places where critical plot points
character interaction or unusual camera
angles occur like the final scene in
Game of Thrones red wedding when
shockingly everybody dies
survey data on that person's political
beliefs along with their psychographic
and demographic data are integrated into
the system to gain a deeper
understanding of the individual let me
give you an example
matching people's TV preferences with
their views on social justice issues
reveal that Americans who rank
immigration among their top three
concerns are more likely to be fans of
The Walking Dead and they often watch
for the adrenaline boost which is
variable a person's biological signature
and their survey response combines into
a database to create their unique media
imprint then our predictive model finds
patterns between media imprints and
tells me which narrative ingredients are
more likely to lead to engagement in
altruistic behavior rather than distress
and apathy the more imprints added to
the database across mediums from
episodic television to games
the better the predictive models become
in short I am
rapping the first media genome whereas
the human genome identifies all genes
involved in sequencing human DNA the
growing database of media imprints will
eventually allow me to determine the
media DNA for a specific person already
the limbic labs narrative engine helps
content creators refine their
storytelling so that it resonates with
their target audiences on an individual
level
the limbic labs other component the
media machine will assess how media
elicits an emotional and physiological
response then pulls scenes from a
Content library targeted to person
specific media DNA applying artificial
intelligence to biometric data creates a
truly personalized experience one that
adapts content based on real-time
unconscious responses imagine if
nonprofits and media makers were able to
measure how audiences feel as they
experience it in alter content on the
fly I believe this is the future of
media to date most media and social
change strategies have attempted to
appeal to mass audiences but the future
is media customized for each person as
real-time measurement of media
consumption an automated media
production becomes the norm we will soon
be consuming media tailored directly to
our cravings using a blend of
psychographics biometrics and AI it's
like personalized medicine based on our
DNA I call it bio media I am currently
testing the limbic lab in a pilot study
with the Norman Lear Center which looks
at the top 50 episodic television shows
but I'm grappling with an ethical
dilemma if I design a tool that can be
turned into a weapon should I build it
by open sourcing the lab to encourage
access and inclusivity
I also run the risk of enabling powerful
governments and profit-driven companies
to appropriate the platform for fake
news marketing or other forms of mass
persuasion for me therefore it is
critical to make my research as
transparent to lay audiences as GMO
labels however this is not enough as
creative technologists we have a
responsibility not only to reflect upon
how present technology shapes our
cultural values and social behavior but
also to actively challenge the
trajectory of future technology it is my
hope that we make an ethical commitment
to harvesting the body's intelligence
for the creation of authentic and just
stories that transform media and
Technology from harmful weapons into
narrative medicine thank you
[Applause]